the alien and Blade Runner franchises
have often been tied together and not
without reason the similarities are
extensive same director in Ridley Scott
similar dystopian societies and of
course terrible representations of care
cuts in the future but do these two
worlds exist in the same universe
[Music]
both Bladerunner and alien deal with the
potential good and evil of artificial
intelligence it always starts out great
helpful machines that have personalities
awesome but it always goes wrong let's
take a look at the robotic bad boys in
each franchise Blade Runner introduces
us to new bioengineered androids
replicants smarter faster stronger and
more resilient than normal human beings
you think they'd know that they're
robots
but created by the Tyrell organization
replicants are implanted with fake
memories as a cushion or pillow for
their emotions I'm kind of unclear why
they don't just drink whisky like
everybody else
the Alien franchise is populated with
synthetics humanoid robots who also
possess impressive AI well certain
replicants don't know if they're human
or not they do die after four years
which really feels more like a pet
hamster than a human synthetics on the
other hand are completely self-aware and
technically immortal these glaring
differences in the software may seem
like enough to dismiss the idea that
replicants and synthetics could be one
in the same thing but hang on listen to
Roy batty and Blade Runner I've seen
attack ships on fire Oh
I watched c-beams glitter in the dark
near the Tannhauser cake could Roy batty
be referencing some of the very same
planets we see in the Alien franchise
movies what if the Tannhauser gate roy
mentions in Blade Runner is the same
gate like structure we see the crew pass
through an alien covenant crap
this leads us to our next category
technology of course the most referenced
and telling connection between alien and
Blade Runner is that they share
essentially the same tech in alien when
Sigourney Weaver prepares to fire up her
escape lifeboat from the Nostromo she
revs the engines by commencing to purge
them this seems like a very clear nod to
the purge screen that appears when DAF
fires up the thrusters for his flying
police cruiser near the beginning of
Blade Runner in fact they are the same
exact screen in both franchises could
this mean that Weyland makes the
spinners not the fidgets spinners yet
damn Millennials get off my lawn later
his gaff and Decker to enjoy a
late-night pleasure cruise in the smog
encrusted sky of LA they do so while
using software that looks identical to
the release clamps used by the Nostromo
alien the connection between the flying
car and Blade Runner and the spaceship
an alien could easily be explained by
Scott just doing his thing and we're
using some of the special effects three
years later however it is possible that
Nostromo is such a piece of junk for
weyland-yutani that it is scrapped
together from technology that is over a
hundred years old and ready to fall out
of the sky this brings us to the last
category these are nearly undeniable
nods from the Creator to a link between
the franchise's thank goodness for that
15 year window when we cared about DVDs
first on the Prometheus UK DVD release
which I'm assuming four people bought in
2013 a pretty interesting Easter Egg can
be found in short it's a memo from Peter
Whelan that seems to suggest that his
mentor was none other than Eldon Tyrell
as you know he was the head of the
Tyrell corporation and Blade Runner who
created the false memory replicants in
the film and the references in the memo
of this unnamed man looking out from a
pyramid and the City of Angels makes it
pretty obvious what this is all about
then there's the 20th anniversary alien
DVD from 1999 which hid deep in its
extras this fascinating easter egg
apparently Tom Skerritt Captain Arthur
Dallas freelanced a stint for the Tyrell
corporation of Blade Runner and a DVD
extra titled Nostromo dossier you can
find a throwaway mention to Dallas
taking a paycheck from tyrell
corporation-- manufacturer of the fabled
replicant bernie are doing north then
there is Scott himself while speaking on
one of many Blade Runner DVD directors
commentaries Scott said this about their
similarities so almost this work could
easily be the city that supports the
crew that go out an alien so in other
words when the crew of alien come back
in they might go into this place and go
into a bar off the street near where
Decker lives that's how I thought about
it [ __ ] that pretty much settles it
ultimately these franchises will always
be tethered together and the links are
fairly undeniable but for you
non-believers maybe there's more
evidence in the new Blade Runner 2049
film that you can't deny and may be
Ridley will finally put this theory to
rest in the alien covenant sequel as a
conspiracy theorist one can only hope
[Music]
you